je rappelle les questions au
Gouvernement la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre
lequillet monsieur le Premier ministre
il y a des jours où l'histoire
s'accélère et bouscule l'ordre mondial
les anathèmes de Donald Trump contre
l'Europe et l'OTAN doivent évidemment
être pris au sérieux comme l'a souligné
François Fillon à Berlin il faut un
sursaut de l'Europe elle doit prendre
son destin en main il faut une Europe
debout qui défende avec ardeur ses
intérêts l'euro face au dollar les
principes de réciprocité et préférence
européennes la défense de nos normes
sanitaires et
environnementales une zone euro
renforcée avec un Fond Monétaire
Européen et l'harmonisation fiscale
entre ses États membres il faut pour
lutter contre l'État islamique créer une
alliance de défense européenne à côté de
l'OTAN comprenant l'Allemagne et pour
suivre la coopération franco-britannique
dans la dynamique de Lancaster House
malgré le brexit nous voulons une Europe
qui défend la civilisation
européenne tout cela ne sera possible
qu'avec un moteur franco-allemand
puissant et pour cela il faut un
rééquilibrage économique de la France
par rapport à l'Allemagne or le
déséquilibre est énorme et va croissant
et de ce fait la voix de François
Hollande sans vision européenne depuis 5
ans est
inaudible quelle ligne européenne V
trois gauches
irréconciliaable adopteront celle de
Monsieur amont à fublé de son revenu
universel à 450 milliards d'euros celle
de Monsieur Mélanchon emporté par sa
fougue anti-européenne ou celle de
Monsieur Macron dont le flou rivalise
avec
l'inconsistance nous les républicains
nous proposons depuis longtemps des
réformes profondes pour redresser la
France parce que c'est son propre
intérêt et aussi celui de l'Europe merci
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marc hraud
ministre des Affaires étrangères et du
développement international oui monsieur
le Président Mesdames Messieurs le
députés monsieur
lequillet pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
toujours
cette tentation qui devient presque un
automatisme à dénigrer la France et à
abaisser la France lorsque vous parlez
de l'Europe ù vous parlez de la présence
de la France dans le monde ce n'est pas
la
réalité et vous et vous monsieur accuez
monsieur le Président
accueillz vous oui leiller
[Musique]
ah lorsque vous évoquez un candidat à la
présidence de la République et que vous
comparez au président François Hollande
dont la voix serait peu écoutée en
Europe vous croyez que celle de celui
que vous soutenez est attendue
aujourd'hui comme la voix de l'espérance
et de l'avenir sérieusement vous pouvez
répondre à cette question alors un peu
de sérieux la relation franco-allemande
pour l'avenir de l'Europe aujourd'hui
est plus nécessaire que jamais monur
chrétien s'il vous plaît c'est la raison
pour laquelle les échanges sont
permanents au plus haut niveau la
semaine dernière nous avons reçu et
assisté à cet entretien qui était à la
fois émouvant et et important avec le
président de la République qui va
allemand qui va quitter ses fonctions le
président président gauk les questions
ont été posées au le plus haut niveau
possible sur les enjeux sur l'avenir de
l'Europe et le rôle que l'Allemagne et
la France doent jouer ensemble j'ai reçu
frankck Walter steinmer qui quittait ses
fonctions et nous avons aussi fait le
point sur l'avenir de et de notre
responsabilité commune le lendemain le
samedi j'ai reçu son successeur zigmar
Gabriel avec la même conviction que
l'Allemagne et la France ont plus que
JAMA met une responsabilité historique
et vendredi c'était le président de la
République avec la chalière allemande
qui seen sont mis d'accord pour répondre
pour dire l'Europe va continuer l'Europe
va pas Laer faire l'Europe c'est pas le
brexit pour le dire en même temps avec
les mêmes mots la même force la même
conviction au nouveau président
américain voilà la voix de la France
Monsieur